MIKE POMPEO TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
IT'S EXPECTED TO SUCCEED BUT
IT'S THE ISSUE OF GETTING IT OUT
OF COMMITTEE.
WE WOKE UP THIS MORNING THINKING
THE NOMINATION WOULD NOT ADVANCE
BECAUSE KENTUCKY
SENATOR RAND PAUL WAS GOING TO
VOTE FOR DEMOCRATS AND IT
WOULDN'T BE ENOUGH.
THERE WAS A CHANGE IN THAT, AND
THEN WE THOUGHT MAYBE HE WOULD
GET OUT OF COMMITTEE WITH WHAT'S
CALLED A FAVORABLE
RECOMMENDATION.
THEN ONE REPUBLICAN SENATOR IS
ABSENT, SENATOR ISAKSON IS IN
GEORGIA ATTENDING A FUNERAL.
NOW THEY ARE DEADLOCKED AT
AT 10-10.
THIS HAPPENED RIGHT BEFORE THIS
MEETING.
HAVING RECEIVED ASSURANCES FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND DIRECTOR
POMPEO THAT HE AGREES WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES, I HAVE DECIDED TO
SUPPORT HIS NOMINATION TO BE OUR
NEXT SECRETARY OF STATE.
HE JOINS DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
HEIDI HEITKAMP, JOE DONNELLY,
AND JOE MANCHIN AND SUPPORTED
THE NOMINATION.
LIKELY ENOUGH TO CONFIRM.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED:
"HARD TO BELIEVE OBSTRUCTIONISTS
MAY VOTE AGAINST MIKE POMPEO
FOR SECRETARY OF STATE.
THE DEMS WILL NOT APPROVE
INCLUDING THE AMBASSADOR TO
GERMANY.
THEY ARE MAXING OUT THE TIME ON
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR ALL,
NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
NEED MORE REPUBLICANS!"
>> MAJORITY OF DEMOCRATS
CONTINUE THEIR POINTLESS
OBSTRUCTION.
A WILLFUL ATTEMPT TO UNDERMINE
AMERICAN DIPLOMACY.
>> DEMOCRATS CLAIM THEY OPPOSE
POMPEO BECAUSE THEY SAY HE WILL
FAIL TO CHECK THE PRESIDENT'S
WORST INSTINCTS.
>> I BELIEVE OUR NATION'S TOP
DIPLOMAT MUST BE FORTHRIGHT.
HIS PAST SENTIMENTS DO NOT
REFLECT OUR NATION'S VALUES AND
ARE NOT ACCEPTABLE FOR THE TOP
TO THE LEFT.
I BELIEVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE BETTER.
>> REPUBLICAN SAY POMPEO HAS THE
TRUST OF THE PRESIDENT AND NOTE
THAT THE SENATE CONFIRMED HIM AS
CIA DIRECTOR.
AS THE NATIONAL SECURITY FOCUSED
NOMINEE, THEY SAY POMPEO
DESERVES CONFIRMATION, JUST AS
THE SENATE EASILY CONFIRMED
SECRETARIES OF STATE FOR
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA,
GEORGE W. BUSH AND THEIR
PREDECESSORS.
REPUBLICAN SAY THEY ARE PUSHING
TO CONFIRM POMPEO.
NATO HAS A MEETING THIS WEEK.
POMPEO SAYS HE WANTS TO BE
THERE.
OFFICIALS WILL LIKELY DISCUSS
THE IRAN NUCLEAR AGREEMENT AT
THE SUMMIT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DEADLINE ON
WHETHER TO WITHDRAW FROM THE
DEAL IS LESS THAN THREE WEEKS
AWAY.
THEN THE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
TRYING TO ESTABLISH THE MEETING
BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
DICTATOR FROM NORTH KOREA
KIM JONG UN.
THAT IS SOMETHING POMPEO HAS
BEEN INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN,
TRAVELING THERE DURING THE
HOLIDAY OVER EASTER WEEKEND.
REPUBLICANS AND POMPEO SAY THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AS A
CONFIRM SECRETARY OF STATE.
STEVE WANT TO BE CLEAR, SO RIGHT
NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET THIS TO THE
FLOOR.
ONCE AND IF IT GETS OUT OF
COMMITTEE TO THE FLOOR BY OUR
VOICE VOTE OR WHATEVER, THEN
THEY WON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
GOING TO VOTE FOR POMPEO.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY HAVE THREE KEY DEMOCRATS
WHO HAVE SAID THEY WILL VOTE FOR
POMPEO.
THEN THEY ALSO HAVE KENTUCKY
SENATOR RAND PAUL.
THEY FEEL THEY'VE GOT ENOUGH.
THEY HAVE TO GET HIM THERE.
THERE ARE SOME PROCEDURAL ISSUES
RIGHT NOW DOING SO, ALL
CONTAINED WITHIN THE COMMITTEE
AND THE MEETING HAPPENING BEHIND